IRFAN BAQUI: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to Apigee Up Close.
I'm Irfan Baqui.
I'm a Customer Engineer
with Google Cloud.
I work very closely
with our customers
to help them make
better Cloud decisions,
Cloud architectural decisions,
and also better API management
decisions.
And today, we'll be
talking about how
to think beyond the gateway.
So let's start with
the objective, right?
What we'll be discussing
today, and what
you'll be getting
out of this talk
is how to be successful
with your APIs,
and have a well-thought-out
strategy driving your API
program.
And just to clear a few
buzzwords here, by strategy,
I really mean looking
at not just your APIs,
but your entire business,
and looking at the metrics
that you're using to drive
your business forward,
and connect your
APIs to help you
achieve those metrics, right?
So that as a whole is
what we call a strategy.
And an API program is
just a collaboration
between your multiple
groups, multiple functions
within your organization to
really drive the strategy.
So here is the agenda.
I'll start by
setting the context
by giving an example of what
a successful API program looks
like.
And I'll do it through
telling you about one
of our customers that
has been thinking very
innovatively about
the API strategy,
and their journey through
multiple years on iterating
through it and really being
successful in the API program.
Then, we will pivot
and we'll talk about
how APIs fit into your
company's architecture,
and what different
approaches you can
take to build your API program.
Security, as we see
it, is a core component
of any API strategy, we'll
talk about that as well.
And finally, we'll
tie all of this
together into the main
subject of today's call,
how to look beyond
the API gateway,
and really think about
API management as a whole
to drive the API program.
And then we'll end it with
questions and answers.
Let's dive right into it, right?
So the successful API program
I want to talk to you about
was of Walgreens.
And it's a very
interesting story.
Back in the days, Walgreens
started as a classic brick
and mortar chain of pharmacies.
And really, it was no different
than any other mom and pop
pharmacy.
The difference was the scale.
They had more than 8,000
stores, and the metric
that they boasted
was that they had
a store within five-mile
distance of 75% of the US
population.
That would have been a
success criteria, right?
Because that's how you
could tell how many people
Walgreens could reach.
And if they were able
to reach those people,
they would be able to
sell things to them,
and that's how
they're successful.
But with the advent
of the digital age,
we're all familiar
with how Amazon
has been disrupting a lot of
different retailers, right?
The classic story is how Amazon
started disrupting Walmart,
and how Walmart really had
to form a unique strategy
to fight back.
Walgreens was a
little different.
They were ahead of the
game, and it basically
started as somewhat
of what I would
call a coincidence, right?
So within the Walgreens,
if you have ever
been in one of the stores,
they have a photo lab
where people, back in
the days, would go in
to develop the photo rolls and
get the pictures out, right?
So with the advent of
smartphones around 2008, around
that time, people stopped
using the photo-roll cameras,
and the smartphones
were smart enough
to take pretty decent
quality images at that time.
So one of the ways
Walgreens was benefiting
from the photo labs was
that people would come in
to develop their
pictures, and as a result,
they would buy something
else as well, right?
So the foot traffic was
very beneficial to them.
But with the advent
of smartphones,
then that had gone down.
So they needed to think
about the customer
and what they wanted,
why did they go away,
and figure out how
they can get them back.
Turned out that
they were looking,
they were still
looking for a way
to print their digital photos.
So what they did was they
created a native application
to let the end users upload
their pictures to the app,
and pick them up developed
at a nearby Walgreens store.
To do this, they had to create
and expose the necessary APIs
to the internal
developers, so that they
could create that application.
So that was good.
That restored some
of their traffic--
not all of it, right?
So they said, all
right, is there
another, bigger opportunity
for us to get more foot
traffic into our stores?
So they looked at how exactly
were the end users interacting
with their photos, right?
What additional things
were they doing it?
What other additional
applications
were they using to
enhance their pictures?
It turned out that
there were a plethora
of other mobile and
web applications
where users would
upload their photos.
For example, for
holiday cards, and they
would decorate the card with
their photos and all of that.
Ultimately, they would
want to print it out.
So they said, all right, how can
I tap into those applications,
and somehow incentivize
the developers
of those applications to
have those photos printed
at a nearby Walgreens, right?
It solved their problem of
getting the photos printed,
and it gave more foot
traffic to Walgreens.
So it was, in their mind,
a win-win situation.
So what they did was now,
they expanded the API program
to expose the APIs to partners
so that they could incorporate
them into their application,
and really created an ecosystem.
So this ecosystem, it
started with photo APIs
and expanded into a
bunch of other services
that they could offer,
like prescription refills,
to medical and health
care applications,
like purchasing their in-store
merchandise with a partner
like Postmates, like
integrating Walgreens reward
programs into other partner
applications, and all of that.
So now with expanding
into an ecosystem,
they were able to really
extend their reach
from one or a handful
of native applications
into hundreds of
partner applications.
And that's huge.
So that was, as a whole, an
example of a successful API
program, right?
But what made Walgreen's
API program successful?
I think the simple
answer is that they
had a relentless focus on
developers and customers,
right?
They started with
their customers first,
they thought about what
exactly they wanted,
and they gave it to them.
And the method of giving it
to them was through APIs,
but it was still connected
to their business strategy.
There were two essential
parts that played a huge role.
And one of them was a developer
portal and incentives.
And this is how
they communicated
with their developers,
with their partners.
In addition to just
exposing the APIs,
they also exposed an
incentive program to them.
They said that hey, for
every dollar, for example--
I'm just making numbers up--
but for every dollar of revenue
that you bring in to the
photo prints API, for example,
I will incentivize you $0.10.
So now, there were
a lot of developers
that were making [? net ?] new
photo applications just to make
revenue out of this program.
So it was very popular.
The second one was analytics.
Once the APIs were
being consumed,
the way they really gauged how
the users and the developers
were accessing,
consuming the APIs
gave them intel on how they
could make them better.
So these two components
were crucial,
beyond just creating
and exposing those APIs.
So let's tie this back into how
you should think about your API
program, right?
There are multiple
different approaches
to building an API
program, but it really
boils down to two major ones.
One is a tactical approach.
And the other one is a
more strategic approach.
So let's talk
about both of them,
and see what are the
pros and cons, right?
So let's talk about
the tactical one first.
Let's make it a fun
exercise, all right?
Let's say you have a CEO
or CTO of your company come
to you to say that,
hey, I've got an idea.
We have this API service
that we should really
broadcast out to our partners.
It would be a mutually
beneficial move, both to us
and the partners, right?
And he gives you the
task to make that happen.
How do you do it?
So let's say now
you are following
the tactical approach.
The first thing you'll do is
you'll identify the service,
and you'll say, hey, how do I
expose this out to, let's say,
just one external
application for now.
And the solution you come to is
just open up a firewall port,
right?
And obviously, you
will need some security
in front of the
service to make sure
that you're allowing
just the people that
should be allowed to access it.
But that's a solution.
All right, you open
up the firewall port,
you add the security
policy there.
The next thing is, what about
rogue applications, right?
They can really
crash your system
if they call too frequently.
In that case, you would just add
a rate limiting functionality
and call it the day.
Next, what if each
API call needs data
from multiple backends?
How would you take care of that?
Let's say you have some
orchestration being performed,
so that an API call comes
in, talks to three, four,
any number of
different backends,
gets their response
back, matches it up,
and passes it back to
that calling application.
Now, do you see what might be
a problem with this strategy?
What's not in focus here?
Well, the customer is
not in focus, right?
You are really thinking about
that particular service,
and how you would expose
it out, but you're
not really thinking about
how to-- who is the customer,
and what experience you
actually want to give them.
Now, let's take a look
at a more strategic way
to look at your APIs.
What you're seeing
on the screen right
now is what we call a digital
value chain, which encompasses
all of the different entities
that would eventually,
in one way or the other,
interact with your APIs.
On the left, you
have your users.
On the right, you have your
backend systems, right?
So traditionally,
what people did
was think about it from more
of an exposure point of view.
And that's what I illustrated
in the previous example.
You have a service, and
you're just thinking
about how do I expose this out?
I would mitigate
some of the problems
around it, like security
and rate limiting
that we talked about,
but essentially, you just
want to expose it out.
But on the other hand,
the success pattern
that we have seen is
the opposite, right?
Think about the users first.
So when your user is
sitting on the table,
opening up their
laptops or interacting
with the mobile application,
what is the experience that you
want to give them?
Once you have identified
that particular experience,
then you have to think about
what kinds of applications
would give them those
experiences, right?
And those applications would
then be made by developers.
So essentially, you
want to make sure
you're giving absolutely
awesome APIs to developers,
so that they don't need to
worry about the complexities
of your systems, and they can
really focus on the experiences
that they're building
for the end users.
And that's really in the
hands of an API team.
And a lot of you
on the call might
be part of such an API team.
You would really
make sure that you're
focusing on the end user,
and also on your developer
first, and creating
those APIs, designing
those APIs such that they
are addressing their needs.
And eventually then, you
would connect those APIs
to your backends, right?
That's where all of the
interesting data and logic
of your enterprise resides.
So you would connect them to
the back ends to get the data,
execute the logic,
and all of that.
This is how you would
strategically view your APIs,
but this also poses
a problem, right?
And that problem is from
a security standpoint.
We talked about all
of these entities
being part of the
digital value chain.
But the more entities
you have, the more effort
you need to put in to make
sure that they're secure.
For example, on the left, you
can have a legitimate end user,
or you can have a hacker,
or you can have a bot.
Some bad actor that really
wants to abuse your API.
You can have really any
application on the internet
interacting with your
APIs, so how do you
identify that it's the
right application that you
have authenticated?
How do you do provision
access of that application
to your system if needed?
So all of that's important.
On the developer side, who
are the developers that
are consuming your APIs, right?
Are they registered?
Do you know them?
Do you-- are you able
to track them well?
And if needed, are you able
to drop them from API program?
Are you able to
deprovision them?
For APIs, are they secure
enough at runtime, right?
Are they following the best
practices and standards
that your organization has laid
out, both from a regulatory
and from a compliance
standpoint?
And finally, your
backend systems.
Is the data coming in and
out of your backend systems
coming in and out securely?
Is it secure?
Is it encrypted addressed?
Is it encrypted in-flight?
And all of that.
And how do you also
make sure that you're
protecting your backend
systems from a certain overload
in the API call volume?
So let's look at how an
intelligent API management
platform would mitigate
some of these threats,
and make sure that
your strategy is also
taking care of security.
So at Apigee, we actually
make sure that each
of these entities are
thought about cohesively.
For example, for
the end user, you
would need
behavior-based security
to identify the
patterns how they're
calling you or your
APIs, and classify them
as either bad actors or
legitimate users, right?
You would also want
signature-based security
to protect your systems against
the well known OAuth attacks.
And you might also want to
do some fine-grained control,
like looking at the payload
complexity, and making sure
that adheres to a
particular schema
that you have defined
for requests coming in.
You may also want to
protect your backend systems
from some abusive
users, if they're
calling the APIs too frequently,
and have them spike arrested.
So you can do all of that
on the end user side.
Also for the
applications, you would
want to make sure that
you're identifying them,
you're authenticating them
through industry standard
or OAuth2 protocols, and you are
restricting them or authorizing
them to access just the APIs
that you give them access to.
Now for developers, you
may want to make sure
that these are your trusted
employees or partners.
And to do so, you
can authenticate them
through an identity provider,
like Okta or PingFederate.
Now talking about
your APIs and API,
teams you'd want to make sure
that your API teams have access
to only the APIs, and even the
functionalities within those
APIs that they should
have access to.
And teams, like
your security team,
are able to set blanket
policies for all of your APIs,
to make sure that
your system is secure.
You'll be able to do all of that
with an API management platform
like Apigee.
Lastly, talking about
your backend systems,
you'd want to make sure
that the connection to them
is secure through something like
mutual TLS and IP whitelisting,
and the data that
flows in and out
is encrypted, both on
the wire and a trust.
So we talked about how to
really look at your API program
strategically, right?
Thinking about the
users first, and also
thinking about security
as you are doing it.
So what exactly is needed
for you to be able to do so?
The first is through
developer management, right?
Having a portal
where your developers
can come in and learn more
about your API program.
Maybe part of it is
your documentation.
Other part of it is monetization
incentives to use your APIs.
Maybe it also has an integration
to your support portal.
Whatever that is,
but any way for you
to quickly onboard and engage
your partners and developers.
Next is analytics, right?
So as they start
consuming your APIs,
you want to see how exactly
they're consuming it, right?
Where are the end users located?
How are they using
the applications?
So you can look at
all of that data
and make your API
program better.
The next is
operations automation.
So as your API program
grows and scales,
you shouldn't really need to
worry about the operations
yourself, right?
You worry about the APIs, you
worry about your products,
and the operations
and everything else
should just happen.
Next is API development.
As you're developing these
APIs, one thing to note
is that they would have to
be developed quickly, right?
Your developers and
their innovation
actually depends on how fast
you are rolling out features.
So that would mean
that ideally, you
would have prebaked policies,
like we provide in Apigee.
Drag and drop, really
quickly change the APIs,
iterate them, version them,
and go to market faster.
And finally, a secure
and flexible API
runtime, so that you can
process the incoming requests
and the responses going out.
So all of this
together is really
a core part of a good
API management platform.
These are features
and functionalities
actually that you get
right now in Apigee.
And one thing to note is
that a very tiny portion
of this functionality
is an API gateway.
So tying this back to the
original idea of our talk
today, thinking beyond
the API gateway,
when you really think about
the users first and make sure
you are tying your API strategy
into your business strategy,
then you would need an
intelligent API management
platform to drive
that API program.